J'ai d'abord dit le script à mon compositeur
John Jewel, je dirais n'importe quoi et il a
tagué son texto m'a renvoyé quelques
heures plus tard et il a dit sombre Goonies
cool et je pense que vous savez vraiment que
les références que nous utilisons étaient ce
genre de ou  les films du début des années 80 sur lesquels j'ai
grandi comme le secret de NIMH et
Goonies et ces films d'Amblin et
c'est un peu comme si vous savez que
la vie d'une famille est comme vous menacée
par quelque chose et c'est une sorte
de sortie mystique ou potentiellement
mystique  Avenue out et je voulais en quelque
sorte faire ma version de cela, vous savez, mais
je suppose en quelque sorte rendre hommage aux
films qui m'ont fait aimer le cinéma au
début, mais aussi ensuite à travers l'objectif
de ce que je ressens à propos du cinéma maintenant
Oh